the weather at the ground level could
bring misery for millions of
Thanksgiving travelers they're dealing
with the heavy snow in the Upper Midwest
holiday traffic jams and powerful winds
that could disrupt the flights and the
snow was blamed for at least one deadly
crash and the storm is moving now
towards the Northeast Don Dahler and
Kris Van Cleave are watching the travel
trouble for us today Don is in
Minneapolis we're gonna start with you
Don good morning to you how much snow do
you expect there hey good morning well
some of these areas could get about a
foot of snow but I would say we have
around six inches here in Minneapolis
it's hard to tell though because this
wind is just whipping the snow around
now Minnesotans know how to deal with
this there are about 800 snowplows out
on the road trying to clear them for the
buses and the commuters a lot of the
schools are closed but I will say even
with that this has disrupted a lot of
people's travel plans this is the
troubling view for thousands of drivers
around the country a near whiteout
dozens of spinouts and crashes were
reported across thousands of miles of
interstates many of which were shut down
for safety a lot of Wazir stranded and
can't get to the locations where we can
be with our families for Thanksgiving
interstate 70 in Eagle County Colorado
was shut down for hours after a
tractor-trailer jackknifed two other
semi slammed into it one of the drivers
was killed to understand a sense of the
danger people face we went out with
driving instructor Jeff Anderson we're
seeing a lot of people sliding off of
road sliding off of highways why is that
they overcorrect they forget I have to
stay calm it's human nature to run away
from a problem to hide from too close
our odds we can't do that we need to
focus where are we going keep our line
of sight where it is we want to go and
that's how we get
the storm slammed Minnesota last night
dumping upwards of 10 inches of snow
across the state go to the other side of
the car and put your backpack in the
divine family in Eden Prairie made their
escape just before this storm hit don't
want to be caught in the roads and also
the traffic because we figure that
there's going to be a max a mass exodus
so we're trying to get on the road
before all of those other cheese hubs
make their way to Wisconsin as the storm
moves northeast authorities are saying
just take it slow and be aware that
these snowplows are out trying to clear
so give them wide berth also you have to
call ahead we see this every time I call
ahead make sure your flight hasn't been
canceled and check for road closures you
really do not want to be stranded out in
this Anthony no you don't done thank you
very much